>>> EVEN AS THE EVACUATION OF
AFGHANISTAN RAMPS UP FOR WHAT
COULD BE THE FINAL SEVEN DAYS,
WE SPOKE TO AMERICANS WHO MADE
IT OUT, PEOPLE SUCH AS SALMA
KAJIMY.
SHE AND HER MOM MADE IT OUT.
THEY ARE BACK IN COLORADO
SPRINGS, AND AFTER THE ORDEAL,
HIDING FROM THE TALIBAN, SALMA
TELLS HER STORY.
>> SO THE DAY WE HAD LANDED,
THERE WAS APPARENTLY A NEWS
STATEMENT THAT CAME OUT THAT THE
TALIBAN WANTED EVERYONE WHO WAS
A CITIZEN TO GET OUT OF AMERICA.
SO LEARNING THE FIRST DAY, WE
WERE KIND OF NERVOUS.
IT WAS MAYBE AFTER TWO WEEKS
THAT WE REALIZED THEY HAD TAKEN
OVER THREE CITIES, WHICH WAS
HERAT AND TWO OTHER ONES.
THEN WE REALIZED THEY WERE CLOSE
TO PALMO M, AND THE NEXT DAY THY
WERE IN KABUL.
>> I TALKED TO CRITICS THE DAY
BEFORE THEY GOT TO KABUL, AND
THERE WAS A THOUGHT THAT MAYBE
IT WOULD BE A FIGHT OR MAYBE IT
WOULD BE WEEKS FROM NOW.
I KNOW YOUR BROTHER BACK IN
COLORADO WAS TRYING TO HELP GET
YOU OUT.
WHEN YOU REALIZED THAT THE
TALIBAN WERE ALREADY IN THE
CITY, WHAT DID YOU DO?
DID YOU JUST STAY INSIDE?
>> YEAH, WE WERE STAYING INSIDE
AND WE WERE TRYING TO CONTACT MY
FAMILY.
WE WERE TRYING TO GET TICKETS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
TICKETS WERE TWICE THE PRICE,
AND THEN AFTER A FEW HOURS, WE
FOUND OUT THE AIRPORT HAD
COMPLETELY CLOSED.
SO WE FELT WE WERE COMPLETELY
STUCK AND HAD NO CHOICE OF
LEAVING.
WE HAD NO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
WE LITERALLY FELT HOPELESS AND
THAT'S WHEN MY FAMILY WAS
FREAKING OUT AS WELL AND
WONDERED IF WE WOULD EVER BE
ABLE TO COME BACK HOME.
>> YOUR BROTHER-IN-LAW WORKS AT
HEWLETT-PACKARD AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO DGET A CHARTER WHICH
HELPED YOU AIM FOR SOMETHING TO
GET TO THE AIRPORT.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE JUST TRYING TO
GET TO THE AIRPORT?
>> IT'S ACTUALLY HPE, HE WORKS
FOR THEM, AND GETTING TO THE
AIRPORT, IT WAS PRETTY SCARY.
SO WE FIRST ACTUALLY WENT TO THE
WRONG GATE, AND WE WERE WAITING
FOR HOURS.
SO MANY PEOPLE WERE JUST
TOGETHER, AND THEN AFTER A
WHILE --
>> WAS GETTING TO THE GATE
ITSELF, GETTING TO THE AIRPORT,
THE ROAD, WERE YOU ABLE TO JUST
DRIVE THERE?
I KNOW THERE WERE TALIBAN
CHECKPOINTS.
>> YES.
SO FIRST OF ALL, THERE WAS
CURFEWS, RIGHT?
WE HAD TO LEAVE LIKE AT 5:00 IN
THE MORNING AFTER THE CURFEW WAS
OVER.
WE WENT TO THE WRONG GATE AND I
GOT OUT OF THE CAR TO SHOW THEM
THAT I HAD AN AMERICAN PASSPORT.
AFTER I GOT OUT, THERE WAS A
LASER ON ME AND THEY SHOT A GUN
A LITTLE WHILE AGO TO SCARE US
OFF, AND SOMEONE TOLD ME THAT
GATE HAD NOT OPENED FOR THREE
DAYS.
I TALKED TO THE CONGRESSMAN AND
WHATNOT, AND HE TOLD ME YOU NEED
TO GO TO ABI GATE.
AS I GOT TO ABI GATE, THERE WERE
SO MANY PEOPLE AROUND US.
IT WAS PRETTY EASY TO GET UP,
BUT ONCE WE GOT THERE, THERE WAS
TALIBAN LINED UP AGAINST THE
AIRPORT.
>> WE'VE SEEN THE CROWDS
OUTSIDE.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE TO TRY TO
MANAGE THAT?
>> IT WAS SO SCARY.
WE WERE SCARED THEY MIGHT TRY TO
OPEN CAR DOORS AND TRY TO TAKE
OUR STUFF AND WHATNOT.
WE DIDN'T FEEL SAFE GOING THERE,
BUT WHEN IT'S NECESSARY, YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH IT, RIGHT?
ONCE WE GOT CLOSER, WE GOT OUT
OF THE CAR AND WE PASSED THE
TALIBAN AND THEY HAD ACTUALLY
STOPPED US.
ONCE THEY STOPPED US, THEY TOOK
MY MOM'S PASSPORT.
WHEN THEY SAW WE WERE AMERICANS,
THEY ACTUALLY LET US THROUGH.
>> THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
>> WE KEPT WALKING FORWARD, AND
WHEN WE GOT TO THE TOP, WE JUST
SEE A WHOLE CROWD OF PEOPLE
PUSHING AND PULLING EACH OTHER,
AND LIKE, ALL WE COULD THINK
ABOUT WAS, IS THIS WHAT WE'LL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH?
MAYBE IF WE CAN TELL THEM WE'RE
CITIZENS, WE CAN GO AROUND THESE
PEOPLE.
NO, WE HAD TO FIGHT JUST AS
MUCH.
SOME PEOPLE HAD NO PAPERWORK,
SOME WERE FROM GERMANY, TURKEY.
WE WERE ALL IN THE SAME MESS AND
THERE WERE KIDS JUST CRYING --
SORRY, I'M REALLY EMOTIONAL --
THEY WERE CRYING AND FAINTING
AND THERE WERE PEOPLE ALL BLOODY
AND HAVING STROKES, AND IT WAS
PROBABLY SOMETHING I WOULD NEVER
EXPECT TO SEE.
>> HOW LONG WERE YOU IN THAT
CROWD?
>> WE WERE PROBABLY THERE FOR
ABOUT FOUR HOURS.
WE WERE PUSHING AND PULLING, AND
THEN, LIKE, I GOT THE ATTENTION
OF ONE OF THE BRITISH SOLDIERS
TELLING THEM WE HAD AN E-MAIL
FROM THE CONGRESS AND THAT WE
HAVE TO GET ON A CHARTER FLIGHT,
THAT WE MIGHT ACTUALLY MISS IT.
HE TOLD ME TO GET CLOSER TO THE
GATE.
THERE WAS, LIKE, BARBED WIRE,
AND LIKE MY MOM'S CLOTHES TORE,
HER HAND WAS BLEEDING, AND WE
HAD TO HELP HER GET ABOVE THOSE
BARBED WIRES.
>> YOU FINALLY DID GET THROUGH.
>> YES.
>> AND I KNOW THAT WHOLE PROCESS
OF FLYING OUT AND THEN NOT
KNOWING WHERE YOU'RE GOING AND
YOU'RE STAYING IN BUNK BEDS, A
LOT OF FAFACILITIES, ALL OF THA
WAS HE CAN TROPICAL STORM
HERMINELY T-- WAS EXTREMELY
EXHAUSTING.
DO YOU THINK THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
GET EVERYONE OUT TO THE U.S.?
>> THEY'LL PROBABLY HAVE TO TAKE
PEOPLE OUT IN HELICOPTERS OR
SOMETHING.
IT WAS GETTING VERY BAD.
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN EVERY DAY
TRYING TO GET PAST THOSE GATES.
THOSE GATES ARE SO HARD TO GET
THROUGH, AND THEY MIGHT HAVE TO
FIND A DIFFERENT WAY.
>> WHEN YOU FINALLY DID GET BACK
TO THE UNITED STATES, HOW ARE
YOU DOING?
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> HONESTLY, LIKE, I FELT
RELIEVED BUT I STILL FEEL
SADNESS.
LIKE, I FEEL LIKE THERE'S STILL
SO MANY PEOPLE TRAPPED IN DANGER
AND I CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
THIS IS WHY I'M DOING THIS
INTERVIEW, I WANT TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE SITUATION THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE STUCK
WHO NEED HELP.
I FEEL LIKE NOBODY IS DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN, BUT I